why is it that human females go through
menopause because i don't think that
many other animals or most other animals
do
hardly any hardly any of those i heard
of one uh
one cetacean some in other words some
sort of a dolphin uh goes through
menopause that's the only other species
i've ever heard of
the the theory is
that
uh at some point a woman reaches a an
age
that humans over time began to become
more and more long-lived and
uh at a certain age
it's more dan if a woman if we live in
social groups we take care of the
members of our group
and if the mother is taking care of her
children and then her grandchildren
her bearing another child
there's the danger she'll die in
childbirth
uh or that she'll die when that child is
young and so it actually it's a an
economic
sense that our genes making an economic
like you know like dawkins talked about
in the selfish gene it isn't like that
our genes actually make decisions but we
can think of them as saying click now
let's switch to this strategy
where i it's better off me being a
grandmother than
dying in childbirth or dying while i
have a very young child and so better to
just invest
i think the reason that it's sort of
unique to humans comes from
because of our brains pregnancy is
particularly dangerous for
moms right like
labor labor is dangerous um and also we
just need a lot of
like
or we benefit a lot from long-term
social support um more so than most
other animals so back
uh
we've talked about this i think dave but
kim hill also did some data where they
actually you know kim hill and hillary
hillard kaplan a number of people have
have analyzed things like the calories
that are brought in by people over their
lifespan in these kind of horticultural
you know groups living
sort of close to the ancestral
circumstances living in the jungles of
south america and they
one of the things that they tell me
is that uh first of all the average
couple
uh doesn't really bring in enough
calories to care for themselves and
their children they're so busy taking
care of the kid they can't bring enough
calories and so they need their
relatives to help them out and their
neighbors to help them out uh and the
average male doesn't bring in enough
calories until he's like 20 years old to
really to be a guaranteed source of
protein
and so because we're so incredibly
dependent in ways that most other
animals were so incredibly dependent
on that risk pool group
that you know that that's what makes us
the special species in which it pays for
the female to
to stop reproducing because she's still
in this group she's still caring for
she's still sharing calories and
time and resources
on the uh on her you know second
generation offspring but she's no longer
continuing to produce more mouths that
need feeding right exactly right
and and she's yeah and she's no longer
she's not taking the risk because
if a woman has a kid
three years before menopause
right and she would have died three
years later that that young
three-year-old is going to be
essentially helpless right so
right so those younger kids especially
the more recent the kid was born
compared to menopause if if there was a
risk of death
the better
right
does this mean that uh menopause
would have only
emerged
after a time when
human females were
growing up to be on average older than
40 years old or 45 years old or
something like that
would have to but there would have to
have been selection pressure operating
at that age for it to
because it's a universal feature of
humans so there would have had to have
been some
selection pressure i guess one other
theory is there could have been a weird
bottleneck where there was only a small
number of human beings and there was a
genetic switch
and one of the females that the only one
that survived that'd be the other
possible theory and it was an accident
ah oh
that is cool but i guess that that could
potentially explain a whole bunch of
phenomenon that we can't really come up
with an explanation for that there's
adaptive explanations that are sometimes
contested wasn't there it was it was a
period that we got to where there was
less than 10 000 homo sapiens on the
planet right and everybody was in
indonesia or something i don't know that
but that
that uh that's interesting if that were
true it would have led to a lot of
bottlenecking and some we might have
some unique characteristics that we
don't really have to have
i i mean it's also possible i don't i
don't know the
like anthropological literature on this
but it's possible that
they say it was a mutation that
worked in a small group and then it just
sort of
lived among humans until we got to the
point where
by and large
women tend to
live
past 40 then
it suddenly becomes incredibly
advantageous and then that's when it
spreads right yes that's that's when it
sort of becomes
that's a good point that's the way it
works
if it had a cost
you know then it would have been
selected out at some point but if it
actually had an advantage
you know that advantage could have
could have
been magnified it's like a latent
benefit almost that sort of sat
idling away and then becomes
significantly more beneficial at some
point and it it's the um
the
fortunate timing of both of those things
coming together that you have the
genetic mutation perhaps at a time when
there's an explosion of that genetic
mutation being advantageous but i
suppose that's what all mutations are
that's the name of the game random
variation and selective retention that
is evolution what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]
you